my husband and I have a bit of debt um I
would say he knows probably about 34 of
it um but he probably doesn't know the
amount of some of it um
Andy does he know about the credit card
debt does he know how bad it is he knows
not totally okay here I'm just gonna be
super honest with you okay um yeah what
I heard in your voice when you started
talking my mind immediately went
to if you are having an affair have you
told him the truth about
everything and just a few minutes later
you say now I told him everything so
this conversation has been very much
about him about him about him about
him I think this conversation is very
much about y'all and very much about you
and it sounds like you're tired of not
being fully honest inside your own home
with the man you said I do with